hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast cilia abnormalities and
developmental defects and loss syndrome
presented by dr. R Claudio Aguilar
associate professor and assistant head
Department of Biological Sciences Purdue
University
I am Xavier Gutierrez of lab routes and
I will be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinth lab routes is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to attain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Aguilar I will now turn the presentation
over to him thank you everyone for
attending and talk so a serious said I'm
gonna be talking about the Celia
abnormalities and developmental defects
in law similar but before going into
that let me tell you a little bit about
our lab our lab is interested in vesicle
trafficking and protein sorting in
health and disease and we're
particularly interested in many vesicle
trafficking events and specifically in
the psychosis and recycling his body
occupies small of our time and we are
interested in this because as you may
know endocytosis is very important for
the distribution of proteins around the
cell but also to control signaling
events within the cell so that is what
makes this process extremely important
for cellular function
such as cell growth and proliferation
still movements and some olives here I'm
giving you some examples to try to
highlight how important this process is
as the endocytosis absolutely require
for nutrient uptake bacterial
phagocytosis synaptic vesicle recycling
interested in understanding how - like
dosas contribute to this process but we
also want to understand how what happens
with some of these elements of the
machinery that makes endocytosis from
are not working properly
in that case we have a simple cell
proliferation now in our control and
therefore we have cancer cell movements
that are now really orchestrated with
the rest of all other processes that are
going on the embryo and therefore get
developmental decisions so it's always
to say that already has to do with
understanding the process of endocytosis
and controlling and proliferation and
cell movement some of the basic research
area while what he has to do with the
understanding how what happened with the
machinery is broken has to do with our
disease oriented research and of course
we want to understand how this processes
contribute to the disease oriented
status so let me tell you a little bit
more about the specific andesitic events
that were interested but interested in
clattering mediated endocytosis as you
know is the most famous of all the
endocytic events or in the city
processes study is very easy to
recognize by the soccer ball looking
like structures that characterize the
clathrin-coated vesicles and the double
initiates with a receptor being bound by
the ligand and the immediate recruitment
of endocytic machinery with interns
recruited the most famous code in
vesicle trafficking is clatter so two of
those players involved in the
recruitment of clattering are called
obscene and the very famous clattering
associated adapter accomplishes wrinkles
years ago thousand years ago we figured
out that the Epson molecule was not only
involved in the recognition of cargo and
bringing clattering to the plasma
membrane but also involving regulators
in the regulation of cell polarity by
interacting with Raja TPS cap regulating
product and this is also one of the
areas in which were very interested in
understanding how signal in his control
by endocytosis a direct interaction of
the deceptive machinery with these
programs but also by the control of the
receptor dynamics in the plasma membrane
and and this is the focus of our stuff
this complex is the focus of our
research here to give you an idea of the
different areas that we cover we are
interested in understanding ligand
binding and how the adoption of
endocytosis occur how the in the sitting
machine is recognized its cargo the pre
membrane proteins that has to be in
generalized I found this connection with
row gaps are important for cell division
cancer and developmental diseases for
example in terms of understanding ligand
binding and induction of endocytosis we
are very interested in using this
knowledge this expertise of many years
in the in the development of novel
therapeutics for bladder cancer and
bladder cancer is very special in the
sense that the euro t liam is the the
material that covers the bladder is
where the tumor cells arise well the
normal cells are covered are protected
from the content of the blood which is
the urine by electro Simon of like a
layers and and tight junctions would not
cure cells usually are less
differentiated they protrude towards the
lumen of the bladder and then therefore
they are more accessible for
therapeutics now the problem is that in
the bladder there is a constant influx
of urine including urea
of course main component which is a
challenge for any therapeutic that is
added to the bladder and also of course
once the blood is suspended by the
of the of the agent of the Kimo the
brother says that as in each void and
therefore need to eliminate variation so
therefore the only or the therapeutic
approach the health future in the
treatment of bladder cancer is a target
trapping approach so something that
somehow he manages to bind to the tumour
cells so that's where we come in with
our expertise of ligand binding and we
have design many different kind of
agents include nanoparticles which are
able to target tumour cells and in order
to do this research not only we work in
vitro but also we work in animal models
including dog stand and mats
and here you just seen a couple of
flashing pictures showing some of our
nanoparticles targeting bladder cancer
cells also we're very interested in how
this protein is recognized at receptors
and particularly we have been working on
understanding how these elements are
able to recognize ubiquitinated proteins
at the plasma membrane specifically some
of them but not others and i hope you're
going to be able to read about this very
soon in the literature but we also been
able to develop i informatique
approaches to try to understand how
these proteins what do they recognize
what kind of sickness lee recognize in
carbs
present in the plasma membrane the niche
in general but I'm going to tell you
today most about this disconnection with
the regulation of knowledge ATP ASE's
through the interaction with all gaps
and with epson and this has to do as I
said with subdivision cancel and the
proper mental diseases so these
regulators are important for cell
polarity as we say answer polarity
particularly with respect to cell
migration and cell division and this was
a project that we initiated in
Saccharomyces cerevisiae and here you
can see a movie in which he shows
Saccharomyces cerevisiae budding yeast
actually budding so what you see is our
normal cells growing apart and simply
the
by this similar in size to the mother
and then they separate so this is this
is the normal behavior of the cells and
either cursor on Epson normal function
but if we introduce a point mutation in
Epson we can contribute you can generate
an accessory with a function of Epson an
uncontrolled function and this is the
result what you're seeing here is an
hyperpolarization of the bot so it once
again connected to cell polarity and on
top of that what you're seeing is the
lack of cell division you can see in
many cases that the cell the mother cell
is growing apart and without separation
from the mother
this new bud grows another bug on top of
it
so that's a very abnormal process so all
these just because we introduced a point
mutation in an industry Tata
we then also obtained evidence that we
interfere with the absent function what
we did is this this kind of a note that
you're seeing here towards the right
which is you can see cells observed by
the AC microscopy and just enjoy Gant
excels in the sample which are cells in
which cell polarity have been completely
abolished there for the delivery of
vesicles for growth it can now be done
to was the bad but it's done against the
whole surface of the cell therefore it
leads to the creation of gigantic cells
and this we could determine that indeed
was due to her gtp a signal in imbalance
well you're seeing here in this Western
block are the putting down activated
cdc42 is that in the presence of the
point mutation tips another researcher
before the activation of cdc42 that is
bound to Chicopee has been decreased and
is about three three eight percent or do
you find in normal cells so definitely
this connection is important for
controlling cell polarity definitely
does shown in yeast but now we wanted to
know how that affects the cell polarity
process in mammalian cells and what we
did is to overexpress have seen first
and you can
that in this picture showing Delia sells
you you know the dresses are all tight
Junction linked they don't move they
don't walk away but when you overexpress
Epson here you can see it by the
expression of its GFP you see this this
green color associated with the cell
that usage was right the morphology
changes of the cell and becomes missing
kind in the shape and actually he gains
the ability to migrate and in other
words mimics an invasive metastasis like
behavior so so and this is actually very
interesting because first of all if you
see this kind of behavior in in cancer
cells which material cells become
malignant becomes invasive by producing
this change the material to mesenchymal
transition and the interesting thing is
that if we inhibit the function of Epsom
by using for example say RNAs which you
have ourselves that can no longer obey
and that's what you're seeing here in
the movie which was the right in which
the cells that have been knocked down
for its same function they land on the
on the on the substrate but they can no
longer move and you see them blaming and
the lower part of movie but actually
that is not a pop ptosis is actually
hyper activation of raw as a product of
the lack of activation of seeds of which
you interact and that's what we see as a
signal in unbalanced as well when we do
similar experiments with what I
described in yeast eponymous I a
serenade Nocturne of epson 1 and 2 you
see the rack activity like one being
lower and we also can detect that lack
of activation by using thread biosensors
that sense in the living cells when the
activation of course and would you see
that the epson double knockdown is
definitely not showing any sign of the
activation of the biosensor so we have a
connection with the disease of this Rho
G DP signaling connection of this
mystic machinery and as I mentioned is
in cancer
I've seen a pin have been seen up
regulated in cancer and we think doesn't
make the cells malignant it makes them
in base we make them micro merit order
but also we've been able to find a
disease in which not only is the
function is up regulated but actually
this is in which the function of this
signaling circuit is impaired and the
rogue app that actually involve
interaction with obscene is called OCR
l1 so OCR l1 is besides being a gap
under sale enacted because we can bind
to rho gtpases but it doesn't induce the
GTP hydrolysis but it also is a
phosphatase molecule called specificity
she was a lipids phosphatase with the
specificity to ORS pip2
as you know I said it's a little bit
that is highly abundant in andesitic
size and also inside some colonize grow
and actually when this with associated
gene is mutated he gives origin to a
terrible disease that is called ocr-a oh
okay ocular cerebral Renison you know or
just loss was first described in the
early 50s and the gene was identified in
the early 90s and as I said is a lipid
phosphatase it produces a triad of
symptoms which is mental retardation
cataracts in both eyes at birth the
babies are very easily recognized from
the cataracts at birth and also renal
dysfunction that is very is detectable
in very early on within a month of birth
you can see the composition of the
earrings affected and he gets only worse
with age and unfortunately it leads to
the premature death of this children
after adolescence the mechanism although
we know the gene and we know the gene is
good for the mechanism of how to three
years these diseases so based on our
previous discovery we postulated that
this should be important for cell phone
rarity as well and considering what we
observed they've seen it should be
involving certain migration at the same
time and here you can see some some like
imaging done on fibroblast obtained from
the skin of normal individuals and also
from two independent in non related
patients come in Los Angeles Long Island
strip and what you see this is a movie
showing the migrations towards the right
of these cells and also you see the
traces of the migration is a if the
computers follows them and calculate the
velocity and persistence of migration
and as you can see the low syndrome
cells are slower and they have a low
persistence of migration and you can see
the many of the cells the trajectories
are not going forward but they are going
sideways sideways and sometimes they are
going backwards we did different kind of
assays to verify this phenotype in
patients and like a scratch assays and
we could verify them they also we need
some migration in transverse and we
could verify the phenotype as well
actually we even identify another
phenotype which was cell spreading if
you imagine this is a very simple test
you lift themselves in suspension sit
them on on a surface for support finally
making coated the cell lands adheres and
then spreads in every direction if you
look at them from the top and that's
what the keratin represents you can see
the nucleus in the center and the cell
is spreading in all directions and it
looks like a surface fried egg and here
you can see the spreading process in
using normal cells and you can see again
the Friday
increase in the center and if you do the
same with no syndrome patient cells this
is what you see and again as I always
said you don't need to be an expert
experience each other the patient cells
are really cannot they can not really do
what the normal cells they are doing so
we can now so
then the spread who seems to be
collapsing all the time and here is just
like imaging of the actin cytoskeleton
as this process occurs so essentially
what I'm telling you here is the notion
of patient cells display defects in cell
migration and in cells spread and what
is why is this important well this is
important because as you know very well
these processes are very important
during embryo formation during
embryogenesis organogenesis so we think
this is the cause for for some of the
developmental defects that we observe we
actually created in collaboration with
Martino colleague in the UK and UK as
well a system in which we use zebrafish
and we use Marcellinus initially to to
inhibit the function of assyria and we
observe also my cell migration defects
in the neural crest cells and then you
see it as a problem with the
differentiation of a cell with my
original presenters to produce the
cartilage of the face of a fish so so we
think we have observed a mechanism for
of this developmental defects so that's
what I was telling you about how this
relates to spreading a migration and we
actually look at the Rosie TPS following
again the same ideas that we saw with
obscene and actually we saw similar
results so the rack is fully activated
in no syndrome patients consistent with
this signaling circuit being less
functional and other colleagues have
been able to demonstrate that he as a
response to a lack in activation of like
one we have a hyper activation of row a
so so we think it definitely this is a
disease that results from the Rosie GPS
signal in imbalance
nevertheless in recent times we've been
able to demonstrate that there is also
another component to the low signal
which is the primary cilia
so and this is a picture that shows
actually for a patient cells the two in
the corners have not been translated we
do see a wall type but the the ones in
the center have been transferred to DG
he also had a wall type and as you can
see the primary cilia here no today
because I've been staying with a set
elated tubulin in red are only present
in the cells that do contain wall type
of ceará the chewy corners do not have
it they do not they can not a single
panel see and we can see that indeed was
well I were more fun
no syndrome animal model shows a problem
in the cilia incarnations is very the
organized so we definitely proposed a
model in which a serial participates of
the trafficking of proteins was the NASA
and primary cilia defects in ocl
function which defects in the assembly
of pregnancy and we could demonstrate
that there is a compartment down just
below the base of the primary cilia in
which OC rl1 co-localize Isis with cargo
here is this chimera contact e.x.p.s P
is a Syrian localization signal and in
local Isis with one international
protein follows the other one is called
a deep channel 7a so this is a
compartment that exists at the base of
the of the city so since then now is the
low signal are being called neuropathy
or sympathy associated disease and this
find is have been corroborated by
multiple investigators in many different
parts of the world why is this important
well it's important because Siri Appa
this is a very populated area of
research there are nutria politics
opportunities surfacing are being tried
pretty much every day and we hope that
we can utilize some of these advances to
actually adapt a more adopt and follow
syndrome treatment
and so I've been telling you so far is
that no syndrome patients percent
probably just say let's put in a
migration but also in primary severe
different so so these are kind of the
first cellular readouts for 4lo syndrome
and we decided that they could be used
to screen for compounds that might
revert these phenotypes and we did that
and so we actually look for compounds
that could for example rescue the cell
is spreading phenotypes here you can see
again the cells the loss interest also
difficulty to spread to the right you
can see some histograms actually showing
that the size the area of the loss of
your senses is prone to be smaller than
the area of the normal cells because of
this spreading defect and we identify a
drug we call candidate one from now that
we have been able to rescue the
spreading phenotype of these patients
Falls pretty but it also we can rescue
the activation sorry the fluid phase
uptake is another penalty under 30 also
depends on how activation Tran control
activation and it's affected in these
patients who can be vested with this
candidate and it also can rescue the
activation of lack so obviously we
immediately asked whether this can be
the number one was able to rescue the
primary cilia defect and unfortunately
the answer was no we cannot
so then what we decided is to look for
drugs that could suppress the primary
cilia phenotype and we did obtain a
candidate core candidate number three
which was able to establish the length
of the primary cilia in cells and was
also able to rescue the calculate
problems in the face of this fish so so
he's a successful candidate to rescue
the family of defects and then we ask
whether he was able to rescue the
spreading in phenotype and unfortunately
the answer was also no and this actually
led us to believe that ocl has a dual
function I think in two different
signaling
which some of them are we pursued by a
candidate drowned and the other pathway
by a different cut so we think in cases
in which both relatives are present in
patients combination combined therapy is
in each with four that we are
collaborating with colleagues in
Northwestern and Indiana University to
create a first legal trial in this
respect but we are now currently
exploring is the possibility also
concern replacement therapy and for that
we were the first ones to take
fibroblasts from the skin of these
patients and create induced pluripotent
stem cells here we can see the markers
of stem cells try 160 in particular the
creation of these colonies are the
fibroblasts and we've been able to
reprogram them or differentiate them as
renal cells and some of the markers are
shown here and we've been able to show
that this do show this same kind of
primary senior defects that we've seen
in fibroblasts either in the reprogram
cells or also in the knockout in HK two
cells but something very interesting
that we see in when we induce the
differentiation of these cells in the
IPS C cells into green ourselves is
there a very important transcription
factor called six-two that there's any
transcription factor in localizes to the
nucleus and you can see that in the
upper row we ask you to focus on the
upper row of images that you see and the
third column you can see six two labeled
red and showing its localization in the
nucleus if you go to the row below that
what you're gonna see is lo syndrome
cells and the red arrow head point out
two nuclei that is actually lacking a
fixture
recently the 6-2 seems to be localized
of miss localized should be Golgi
apparatus and actually that's a place
where OCR a lot Eliza so we think it's
connected and in fact we we suspected
that this miss localization of six to
outside of the nucleus it could be
related to problems with the phosphatase
activity of your syndrome and therefore
we use lithium chloride which is the
lower of the rose and you can see in the
sixty two column the six choose again
localized at the nuclei upon addition of
Britain color Legion chloride what it
does it inhibits the synthesis of pip2
the substrate of a Cheryl one so what we
are seeing here is a critical
transcription factor that he cannot
reach his target impatient sauce not at
least sufficiently and therefore we
speculate that this will produce
problems for the generation of all the
cellular lineages that depends on six to
during the development of the Kidman's
and along the lineages affected will be
the proximal tubule cells which are
actually known to be affected in this
patients and would you see towards the
rider just quantification of the effects
not just described for you so and
actually we do see an imbalance in the
generation of different lineages in this
kidney cells in vitro we see for example
CKD a positive cells which are
representatives of the duct which are
overrepresented in lo syndrome as
opposed to normal so that's their the
reason is because six to he can now
fulfill its function therefore these
cells are then induced you to
differentiate into different lineage
duct lineages so and we could reproduce
this phenotype of six to miss
localization by using again a also a
really knockout cells HK to make in the
sauce
so next step in
now work is to prepare kidney organelles
and we actually showing you here a
picture of one of our first kidney
organelles and stained by the different
sub silly different cell types that make
the nephron defendant effluence so so we
are very excited about this and trying
to be able to recapitulate the
difference the production of a kidney in
vitro and study the defects that law
syndrome imposes on to these
organizations process without a finish
not before acknowledging first of all
the people in the lab participated in
these processes and they saw the process
of developing these different lines of
research we probably summarized about
ten years of research in this
presentation
Brian Kuhn was one of the person that
initiated this research was followed by
Cal Cal McKee Bannon both of them are
successful positives in jail and in
scripts respectively and then the people
in the lab they'll continue the research
Claudia Hanna when she showed up at the
second McKee Peterson and we'll have our
undergrad helpers Chinna and Brittany
and Schroder and we J up in very
instrumentals for developing what I just
described today particularly when J for
the IPS C and reprogramming that I
described and Shwetha for the
identification and characterization of
the candidate drops for for
can't counteract the effects of loss
syndrome and then my collaborators in
the UK field bills and Martin low donor
faculty in our Institute for eternity
neuroscience and Phil now in the drug
discovery center these two collection
for you have been instrumental
donor for the idea C story and feel for
continuing the developing of therapeutic
approaches against loss and what you can
see then there is
our funding agencies in H&M safe but
also wanna highlight the low Syndrome
Trust which gave us funds to initiate
all this research and the low signal
Association as well and now is continue
to fund earnest as well as the Indiana
clinical and translational science
Institute recently giving us money to
continue with this research and without
that I will just finish and take any
questions mr. Cabot I would like to
thank dr. Aguilar for his presentation I
would also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through December of 2018 you will
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's event that's all
for now thank you for joining us and we
hope to see you again soon goodbye